all right hello everyone I'm today going
to talk about this paper about how
Facebook uses memcache I'm in order to
handle enormous load the reason we're
reading this paper is that it's an
experience paper there's not really any
new concepts or ideas or techniques here
but it's kind of what a real live
company ran into when they were trying
to build very high capacity
infrastructure there's a couple of ways
you could read it one is a sort of
cautionary tale about what goes wrong if
you don't take consistency seriously
from the start another way to read it is
that it's an impressive story about how
to get extremely high capacity from
using mostly off-the-shelf software
another way to read it is that it's a
kind of illustration or the fundamental
struggle that a lot of setups face
between trying to get very high
performance which you do by things like
replication and how to give consistency
for which techniques like replication
are really the enemy and so you know we
can argue about whether we like their
design or we think it's elegant or a
good solution but we can't really argue
with how successful they've been so we
do need to take them seriously and for
me actually this paper which I first
read quite a few years ago it's been I
thought about it a lot and it's been
sort of a source of sort of ideas and
understanding about problems at many
points
all right so before talking about
Facebook proper you know they're an
example of a pattern that you see fairly
often or that many people have
experienced in which they're trying to
build a website to do something and you
know typically people who build websites
are not interested in building high
performance you know high performance
storage infrastructure they're
interested in building features that
will make their users happy or selling
more advertisements or something you
know so they they're not gonna start by
spending a main year of effort or a
whole lot of time building cool
infrastructure they're gonna start by
building features in that they'll sort
of make infrastructure better only to
the extent that they really have to
because you know that's the best use of
their time alright so a typical starting
scenario in a ways when a some website
is very small is you know there's no
point in starting with anything more
than just a single machine right you
know maybe you started you only have a
couple users sitting in front of their
browsers and you know they talk over the
internet here with your single machine
your single machine is gonna maybe run
the Apache web server now maybe you
write the scripts that produce web pages
using PHP or Python or some other
convenient easy to program sort of
scripting style language and Facebook
uses PHP you need to store your data
somewhere or you can just download sort
of standard database and Facebook happen
to use my sequel my school is a good
choice because it implements the sequel
query language is very powerful and acid
transactions provides durable storage so
this is like a very very nice set up I
am will take you a long way actually but
supposing supposing you get successful
you get more and more users you know
you're gonna get more and more load more
and more people gonna be viewing your
website and running whatever PHP stuff
you're with
site provides and so at some point
almost certainly the first thing that's
going to go wrong is that the PHP
scripts are gonna take up too much CPU
time that's usually the first bottleneck
people encounter if they start with a
single server so what you need is some
way to get more horsepower for your PHP
scripts and so that takes us to kind of
architecture number two for websites in
which you know you have lots and lots of
users right or more users than before
you need more CPU power for your PHP
scripts so you run a bunch of front end
servers whose only job is to run the web
servers that users browsers talk to and
these are called front end servers so
these are going to run a patch either
webserver and the PHP scripts now you
know you users are going to talk to
different servers at different times
maybe your users Quadra each other they
message each other they need to see each
other's posts or something
so all these front-end servers are going
to need to see the same back-end data
and in order to do that you probably
can't just stick at least for a while
you can just stick with one database
server so you gonna have a single
machine already my sequel that handles
all of the database all queries and
updates reads and writes from the front
end servers and if you possibly can it's
wise to use a single server here because
as soon as you go with two servers and
somehow your data over multiple database
servers like gets much more complicated
and you need to worry about things like
do you need distributed transactions or
how it has the PHP scripts decide which
database server to talk to and so again
you can get a long way with this second
architecture you have as much CPU power
as you like by adding more front end
servers and up to a point a single
database server will actually be able to
absorb the reason rights of many front
ends but you know maybe you're very
successful you get even more users and
so the question is what's gonna go wrong
next and typically what goes wrong next
is that the database server since you
can always add more CPU more web servers
you know what inevitably goes wrong is
that after a while the database server
runs out of steam okay so what's the
next architecture this is web
architecture 3 and the kind of standard
evolution of big websites here we have
the same if you know now thousands and
thousands of users lots and lots of
front ends and now we basically we know
we're gonna have to have multiple
database servers so now behind the front
ends we have a whole rack of database
servers each one of them running my
sequel again
but we're going to shard the data
we're driven now to sharding the data
over the database server so you know
maybe the first one holds keys you know
a through G & G through second one holds
keys G through Q and you know whatever
the charting happens to be and now the
front-end you know you have to teach
your PHP scripts here to look at the
data they need and try to figure out
which database server they're going to
talk to it you know in different times
for different data they're going to talk
to different servers so this is sharding
and of course the reason why this gives
you a boost is that now the all the work
of reading and writing has split up
hopefully hopefully evenly split up
between these servers since they hold
different data now replicas rating word
charting the data and they can execute
in parallel and have big parallel
capacity to read and write data it's a
little bit painful the PHP code has to
know about the sharding if you change
the setup of the database servers that
you add a new database server or you
realize you need to split up the keys
differently you know now you need a
you're gonna have to modify the software
running on the front ends or something
in order for them to understand about
how to cut over to the new sharding so
there's some there's some pain here
there's also if you need transactions
and you know many people use them if you
need transactions but the data involved
in a single transaction is on more than
one database server you're probably
going to need two-phase commit or some
other distributed transaction scheme
it's also a pain and slow all right well
you can you can get fairly far with this
arrangement however it's quite expensive
my sequel or sort of you know fully
featured database servers like people
like to use it's not particularly fast
it can probably
perform a couple hundred thousand reads
per second and far fewer rights and you
know web sites tend to be read heavy so
it's likely that you're gonna run out of
steam for reads before writes that
traffic will be that we load on the web
servers will be dominated by reads and
so after a while you know you can slice
the data more and more thinly over more
and more servers but two things go wrong
with that one is that the some sometimes
you're you have specific keys that are
hot that are used a lot and no amount of
slicing really helps there because each
key is only on a single server so that
keeps very popular that servers can be
overloaded no matter how much you
partition or shard the data and the
other problem with adding was shorting
adding lots and lots of my sequel
database servers for sharding is that
it's really an expensive way to go as it
turns out and after a point you're gonna
you're going to start to think that well
instead of spending a lot of money to
add another database server running my
sequel I could take the same server run
something much faster on it like as it
happens memcache D and get a lot more
reads per second out of the same
Hardware using caching than using
databases so the next architecture and
this is now starting to resemble what
Facebook is using the next architecture
still need users we still have a bunch
of front end servers running web servers
in PHP and by now maybe a vast number of
front end servers we still have our
database servers because you know we
need us a system that will store data
safely on disk for us and we'll provide
things like transactions for us and so
you know probably want a database for
that but in between we're gonna have a
caching layer that's this is where
memcache D comes in
and of course there's other things you
could use that the memcache but memcache
D happens to be an extremely popular
caching scheme the idea now is you have
a whole bunch of these memcache servers
and when a front-end needs to read some
data the first thing it does is ask one
of the memcache servers look do you have
the data I need
so it'll send a get request with some
key to one of the memcache servers and
the memcache server will check it's got
just a table in memory it's in fact
memcache is extremely simple it's far
far simpler than your lab 3 for example
it just has just as a big hash table on
memory it checks with that keys in the
hash table if it is it sends back the
data saying oh yeah here's the value
I've cashed for that and if we if the
front end hits in this memcache server
great I can then produce the webpage
with that data in it if it misses in the
webserver though the front-end has to
then rear equesticle irrelevant database
server and the database server will say
oh you know here's the here's the data
you need and at that point in order to
cash it in for the next front-end that
needs it the front end we'll send a put
with the data it fashion the database
into that memcache server and because
memcache runs at least 10 and maybe
maybe more than 10 times faster for
weeds than the database for a given
amount of hardware it really pays off to
use a fair amount some of that hardware
for memcache as well as for the database
servers so people people use this
arrangement a lot and it just saves them
money because memcache is so much faster
for weeds than a database server still
need to send writes to the database
because you want right to an updates to
be stored durably on the database as
this can still be there if there's a
crash or something but you can send the
Reese to the cache very much more
quickly ok so we have a question the
question is why wouldn't the memcache
server actually hit the put on behalf of
the front-end and cache the response
before responding the front-end so
that's a great question
you could imagine a caching layer that
you would send a get to it and it would
if it missed the memcache layer would
would forward the request to the
database babies respond the memcache
memcache would add the data to its
tables and then respond and the reason
for this is that memcache is like a
completely separate piece of software
that it doesn't know anything about
databases and it's actually not even
necessarily used and combined in
conjunction with the database although
it often is so we can't bake in
knowledge of the database into memcache
and sort of deeper reason is that the
front ends are often not really storing
one for one database records in memcache
almost always or very frequently what's
going on is that the front-end will
issue some requests to the database and
then process the results somewhat you
know maybe take a few steps to turning
it into HTML or sort of collect together
you know results from multiple careers
on multiple rows in the database and
cached partially processed information
in memcache
just to save the next reader from having
to do the same processing and for that
reason memcache it doesn't really does
not understand the relationship between
what the friends would like to see see
cached and how did you ride that data
from the database that knowledge is
really only in the PHP code on the front
end so therefore even though we could be
architectural a good idea we can't have
this integration here sort of direct
contact between memcache and the
database although it might make the
cache consistency story much more
straightforward and yes
this is it's this and answer the next
question that is the difference between
a lookaside cash and a look through cash
the fact the lookaside business is that
the front end sort of looks asides to
the cash to see if the data is there and
if it's not it makes its own
arrangements for getting the deed on
amiss you know a look through cash my
forward request of the database and
directly and handle the response now
part of the reason for the popularity in
memcache is that it is it is a lookaside
cash that is completely neutral about
whether there's a database or what's in
the database or the relationship between
stuff in memcache and what's in the end
items in the database all right so this
is very popular arrangement very widely
used it's cost effective because
memcache is so much faster in the
database it's a bit complex every
website that makes serious you so this
faces the problem that if you don't do
something the data that's stored in the
caches will get out of sync with the
data in the database and so everybody
has to have a story for how to make sure
that when you modify something in the
database you do something to memcache to
you know take care of the fact that
memcache may then be storing stale data
that doesn't reflect the updates and a
lot of this papers about what Facebook
story is for that although other people
had other plans this arrangements also
potentially a bit fragile it allows you
to scale up to far more users then you
could have gone with databases alone
because memcache is so fast but what
that means is that you're gonna end up
with the system that's sustaining a load
that's far far higher you know orders of
magnitude higher than what the databases
could handle and thus if anything goes
wrong for example if one of your
memcache servers were to fail and
meaning that the front ends would now
have to contact the database because
they didn't hit they couldn't use this
to store data
you're gonna be increasing a load in the
databases dramatically right because
memcache do you know supposing it has a
you know hit rate of 99 percent or
whatever it happens to be you know
memcache is gonna be absorbing almost
all the reads the database backends only
going to be seeing a few percent of the
total reads so any failure here is gonna
increase that few percent of the reads
to maybe you know I don't know 50
percent of the reads or whatever which
is a huge huge order of magnitude
increase so as Facebook does once you've
got to rely on this caching layer you
need to be set up pretty serious
measures to make sure that you never
expose the database layer to the full
anything like the full load that the
caching layer is seeing and you know you
see in facebook they have quite a bit of
thought put into making sure the
databases don't ever see anything like
the full load okay
so far this is generic now I want to
sort of switch to a big picture of what
Facebook describes in the paper for
their overall architecture of course
they have lots of users every user as a
friendless and status and posts and
likes and photos but Facebook's very
easy or e nted towards showing data to
users and a super important aspect of
that is that fresh data is not
absolutely necessary in that
circumstance you know suppose the reads
are you know due to caching supposed to
reads yield data that's a few seconds
out of date so you're showing your users
data not the very latest data but the
data from a few seconds ago you know
what the users are extremely unlikely to
notice except in special cases right if
I'm looking at a news feed of today's
you know today's news you know if I see
the news from a few
times ago versus the news from now a big
deal nobody's gonna notice nobody's
gonna complain you know that's not
always true for all data but for a lot a
lot of the data that they have to deal
with sort of super up-to-date
consistency in the sense of like
linearise ability is not actually
important what is important is that you
don't cache stale data indefinitely you
know what they can't do is by mistake
have some data that they're showing
users that's from yesterday or last week
or even an hour ago those users really
will start to notice that so they don't
care about consistency like
second-by-second but they care a lot
about not not being in cannot chewing
stale data from more than well more than
a little while ago the other situation
in which they need to provide
consistency is if a user updates their
own data or if a user updates almost any
data and then reads that same data that
the human knows that they just updated
it's extremely confusing for the user to
see stale data if they know they just
changed it and so in that specific case
the Facebook design is also careful to
make sure that if a user changes data
that that user will see the change data
ok so Facebook has multiple data centers
which they call regions and I think at
the time this paper was written they had
two regions their sort of primary region
was on the west coast California and
their sort of secondary region was in
the East Coast and the two data centers
look pretty similar you
set of database servers running my
sequel the sharted date over these my
sequel database servers
they had a bunch of memcache D servers
which we'll see they are actually
arranged in independent clusters and
then they had a bunch of front ends
again sort of a separate arrangement in
each data center and there's a couple
reasons for this one is that their
customers were scattered all over the
country and it's nice just for a
performance that people on the East
Coast can talk to a nearby data center
and people on the west coast can also
talk to a nearby deficit it just makes
internet delays less now the the data
centers were not symmetric each of them
held a complete copy of all the data
they didn't sort of shard the data
across the data centers so the West
Coast I think was a primary and it sort
of had the real copy of the data and the
East Coast was a secondary and what that
really means is that all rights had to
be sent to the relevant database and the
primary day to be Center so you know any
right gets sent you know here and they
use a feature of my sequel they serve
asynchronous log replication scheme to
have each database in the primary region
send every update to the corresponding
database in secondary region so that
with a lag of maybe even a few seconds
these database servers would have
identical content the secondary database
servers would have identical content to
the primaries reads though we're local
so these front ends when they need to
find some data I'm in general would talk
to memcache memcache in that data center
and if they missed in memcache they
talked to the they'd read from the
database in that same data data center
um again though the databases are
complete replicas all the data's on both
of these these in both of these regions
that's the overall picture the next
thing I want to talk about is a few
details about how they how they use you
know with this leukocyte caching
actually looks like so there's really
there's reads and writes and this is
just what's shown in Figure two for a
read
which is executing on a front-end the
first thing if you read any data that
might be cached the first thing that
code in the front-end does is makes this
get library call with the key of the
data they want and get just generates an
RPC to the relevant memcache server so
they hash this library routine hashes on
the client hashes the key to pick the
memcache server and sends an RPC to that
mcat server them casually reply yes
here's your data or or maybe it'll point
nil saying I don't have that data it's
not cached so if if V is nil then the
front-end will issue whatever sequel
query is required to fetch the data from
the database and then make another RPC
call
- memk2 the relevant memcache server to
install the fetch data in the memcache
server so this is just the routine I
talked through before
it's kind of what lookaside caching does
and for right
you know V is the writing we have a key
and a value no Rana right and so library
routine on an each front end we're gonna
send the the new data to the database
and you know I as I mentioned before the
Keene the value may be a little bit
different you know what's stored in the
database is often in a somewhat
different form from what's stored in
memcache see but we'll imagine for now
the same and once the database has the
new data then the right library routine
sends an RPC to memcache detailing it
look you got to delete this key so I
want to write the writer is invalidating
the key in memcache do you know what
that means is that the next front-end
that tries to read that key from
memcache D is gonna get nil back because
it's no longer cached and will fetch the
updated value from the database and
install it into memcache all right so
this is an invalidation in particular
it's not you could imagine a scheme that
would send the new data to memcache T at
this point but it doesn't actually do
that instead of gliese it and actually
in the context of facebook scheme the
real reason why this delete is needed is
so that
we'll see their own rights because in
fact in their scheme the mem cat the my
sequel server the database servers also
send deletes one of you and the front
end writes something in the database the
database with the mix squeal mechanism
the paper mentions well send the
relevant deletes to the memcache servers
that that might hold this key so the
data the database servers will actually
invalidate stuff in memcache by-and-bye
may take them a while um but because
that might take a while the front ends
also delete the key said that a front
end won't see a stale value for data
that it just updated okay
all sort of the background of this is
pretty much how everybody uses memcache
G there's nothing yet really very
special here now eventually you know the
paper is all about on the surface all
about solving consistency problems and
indeed those are important but the
reason why they got where they ran into
those consistency problems is in large
part because they you know modify the
design or set up a design that had
extremely high performance because they
had extremely high load and say they
were desperate to get performance and
kind of struggled along behind the
performance improvements in order to
retain a reasonable level of consistency
and because the performance kind of came
first for them I'm actually going to
talk about
their performance architecture before
talking about how they fix the
consistency okay sorry there's been a
bunch of questions here that I haven't
seen let me take a peek okay so one
question this means that the replicated
updates from the primary my sequel
database to the secondary must also
issue deletes - yeah so this is I think
a reference to the previous or
architecture slide the observation is
that yes indeed when a front-end sends a
write to the database server today every
server updates its data on disk and it
will send an invalidate a delete to
whatever memcache server there is in the
local region the local data center that
might have had the key that was just
updated the database server also sends a
sort of representation of the update to
the corresponding database serve in the
other region which process it applies
the right to its disk data on disk it
also using them excuse sort of log
reading apparatus figures out which
memcache server might hold the key that
was just updated and sends it delete
also to that memcache server so that the
if it's the key is cache is invalidated
in in both data centers okay so another
question what would happen if we delete
first in the right and then send to the
database
so that's or with reference to this
thing here would what if we did to the
feet first you know if you do delete
first then you're increasing the chances
that some other clients so supposing you
delete and then send to database right
in here if another client reads that
same key they're gonna miss at this
point they're gonna fetch the old data
from the database and they're gonna then
insert it
cash and then you're going to update it
leaving memcache for a while at least
with stale data and then if this the
writing client reads it again it may see
the stale data even though it just
updated it doing the delete second um
you know these over the possibility that
somebody will read during this period of
time and see steal data but they're not
worried about stale data in general
they're really most worried in this
context about clients reading their own
rights so on balance even though there's
a consistency problem by the way I'm
doing the delete second ensures that
clients will be their own rights in
either case eventually the database
server as I'm just mentioned will send a
delete for the written keys
another question I'm confused on how
writing the new value shows stale data
but deleting doesn't let me see I'm not
really sure what the question is asking
the if it's with reference to this code
once the writes done okay maybe the
question is it's really we didn't do
delete at all so that when a client a
front web for an end did or wanted to
update him David would just tell the
database but not explicitly delete the
data from memcache the problem with this
is that if the client sent this write to
the database and then immediately read
the same data that read would come out
of the memcache and because memcache
still has the old data
you know memcache hasn't seen this right
yet a client that updated some data and
then read it you know updates it in the
database but it reads the data if the
stale data from memcache and then a
client might update some data but still
see the old data and if you delete it
from memcache then if a client if you do
do this delete than a client that writes
some data and deletes it from memcache
and then reads it again it'll miss in
memcache because of the delete and they
don't have to go to the database and
read the data and the database will give
it fresh data okay so the question is
how come why do we delete here
gosh why don't we just instead of this
delete have the client just directly
since it knows the new data just send a
set RPC - memcache T and this is a this
is a good question
and so here we're doing I have an
invalidate scheme this would often be
called an update scheme and let me try
to cook up an example that shows that
while this could probably be made to
work this update scheme it doesn't work
it doesn't work out of the box and you
wouldn't you need to do some careful
design in order to make it work so this
wasn't client wants posing up now we
have two clients
reading and writing the same key
interleaved so let's say client one
tells the database you know sends X plus
plus to the database right just
incrementing X and then of course or let
me say it's going to increment X from
zero to one so set X to one and then
after that client one is going to call
set of our key which is X and the value
one and write that at the memcache D
supposing meanwhile client two also
wants to increment X so it's going to
read this latest value in the database
and almost certainly these are in fact
transactions so what if we were doing
increment what client won't won't be
sending would be some sort of increment
transaction on the database for
correctness because the database does
support transactions so we're going to
imagine the client to increments the
value of x to to sends that increment to
the database and client two also is
going to do this set so it's going to
set X to be two but now what we're left
with is the value of one in memcache D
even though the correct values and the
databases to which is to say if we do
this update was set even though it does
save us some time right cuz now we're
saving somebody a miss in the future
because we directly said instead of
delete we also run the risk if the if
it's popular data of leaving stale data
in the database it's not that you
couldn't get this to work somehow but it
does require some careful thought to fix
this problem all right so that was why
they use invalidate and instead of
update okay so I was going to
about performance they this sort of
route of how they get performance is
through parallel parallelization
parallel execution and for a storage
system just at a high level there's
really two ways that you can get a good
performance
one is by partition which is sharding
that is you take your data and you split
it up over you know into ten pieces over
ten servers and those ten servers can
run independently hopefully the other
way you can use extra hardware to get
higher performance despite replication
at is have more than one copy of the
data and you kind of for a given amount
of hardware you can kind of choose
whether to partition your data or
replicate it in order to use that
hardware and there's you know from
memcache see what we're talking about
here is is splitting the data over the
available memcache servers by hashing
the key so that every key sort of lives
on one memcache server and from memcache
what we would be talking about here is
having each front-end just talk to a
single memcache server and send all its
requests there so that each memcache
server serves only a subset of the front
ends and sort of serves all their needs
and Facebook actually uses a combination
of both partition and replication for
partition the things that are in its
favor one is that it's memory efficient
because you only store a single copy of
each item Abita where's in replication
you're gonna store every piece of data
maybe on every server on the sort of
partition is that it's as long as your
keys are sort of equally roughly equally
popular works pretty well but if there's
some hot a few hot keys partition
doesn't really help you much once you
get those partition enough that those
hot keys are on different servers you
know once the if there's a single hot
key for example no amount of
partitioning helps you because no matter
of how much you partition that hot key
is still sitting on just one server
the problem partition is that it doesn't
mean that the front if front ends need
to use lots of data lots of different
keys it means in the end each front-end
is probably going to talk to lots of
partitions and at least if you use
protocols like TCP that keep state
there's significant overhead to as you
add more and more sort of N squared
communication for a replication it's
fantastic if if your problem is that a
few keys are popular because now you
know you're making replicas of those
those hotkeys and you can serve each
replica the same key in parallel it's
good because there's fewer this there's
not n squared communication each
front-end maybe only talks to one
memcache server but the bad thing is
it's there's a copy of data in every
server you can cache far fewer distinct
data items with replication then with
partition so there's less total data can
be stored so these are just generic for
pros and cons of these two main ways of
using extra hardware to get higher
performance alright so I want to talk a
bit about there when one sort of context
in which they use partition and
replication is at the level of different
regions so I just want to talk through
why it is that they decided to have
separate regions and kind of separate
complete data center with all the data
in each of the regions so I before I do
that there's a question why can't we
cache the same amount of data with
replication ok so supposing you have 10
machines each with a gigabyte of RAM and
you can use these 10 machines each with
a gigabyte of RAM for either replication
or in a partitioning scheme if you use a
partitioning scheme where each server
stores different data from the other
servers that you can store a total of 10
gigabytes of distinct data objects on
your 10 servers each with a gigabyte of
RAM so with partition you know each byte
of ram is used for different data so you
can look at the total amount of RAM you
have that's how much distinct data you
know different data items you can store
with replication you know assuming your
users are more or less looking at the
same stuff each each replicas each cache
replicas will end up storing roughly the
same stuff as all the other caches so
your 10 you have 10 gigabytes of RAM
still they and your 10 machines but each
of those machines stores roughly the
same data so would you end up with this
10 copies of the same gigabyte of items
so in a can this particular example if
you use replication you
snoring attempt as many distinct data
items and you know that may actually be
a good idea depending on you know sort
of way your data is like but it does
mean that replication gives you less
total data that's cached and you know
you can see there's points in the paper
word that they mention this tension
nominally they don't come down on one
side of the other because they use both
replication and charting okay okay so
the highest level at which they're
playing this game is between regions and
so it at this high level each region has
a complete replica of all the data right
they have a each region as a complete
set of database servers each database
database corresponding database servers
for the same data and assuming users are
looking at more or less the same stuff
that means the memcache servers in the
different regions are also storing more
or less basically replicating where we
have yours replicating in both the
database servers and the memcache
servers and the point again one point is
to you want a complete copy of the site
that's close to West Coast users in the
internet load early in the internet and
another copy of the complete website
this close to users on the East Coast
close on the internet again and the
Internet's pretty fast but coast to
coast is you know 50 milliseconds or
something which if you do if users have
to wait too many 50 millisecond
intervals they'll start to notice that
amount of time another reason is that
the you wanna a reason to
applicate the data between the two
regions is that these front ends to even
create a single web page for user
requests often dozens or hundreds of
distinct data items from the cache or
the databases and so the speed the
latency the delay at which a front-end
can fetch these hundreds of items from
that from the look from the memcache key
is quite important and so it's extremely
important to have the front and only
talk to only read local memcache servers
and local databases so that you can do
the hundreds of queries it needs to do
for a web page very rapidly so if we
have partitioned the data between the
two regions then a front-end you know if
I'm looking at my friends and some of my
friends are on the East Coast and some
on the west coast that means if we
partitioned that would might require the
front ends to actually make many
requests you know 50 milliseconds each
to the other data center and users would
users would see this kind of latency and
be very upset so so the reason to
another reason to replicate is to keep
the front ends always close to the data
to all the data they need of course this
makes writes more expensive because now
if a front-end and the secondary region
needs to write in estes send the data
all the way across the internet the
reads are far far more frequent than
right so it's a good trade-off although
the paper doesn't mention it it's
possible that another reason for
complete replication between the two
sites is so that if the primary site
goes down perhaps they could switch the
whole operation to the secondary site
but I don't know if they had that in
mind
okay so this is the story between
Regents is basically a story of
replication between the two data centers
all right now within a data center
within a region so in each region
there's a single set of database servers
so at the database level the data is
charted and not replicated inside each
region however at the memcache level
they actually use replication as well as
charting so they had this notion of
clusters so a given regions actually
supports multiple clusters of front-ends
and database servers so here I'm going
to have two clusters in this region this
cluster has a you know a bunch of front
ends and a bunch of memcache servers and
these are completely independent almost
completely independent so that a
front-end and cluster one sends all its
reads to the local memcache servers and
misses it needs to go to the one instead
of database servers and similarly each
front-end in this cluster
talks only to memcache servers in the
same cluster so why do they have this
multiple clusters why not just have you
know essentially a single cluster a
single set of front end servers and a
single set of memcache server is shared
by all those front ends one is that if
you did that and and that would mean you
know if you need to scale up capacity
you sort of be adding more and more
memcache servers in front ends to the
same cluster you don't get any win
therefore in performance for popular
Keys you know so there the data sort of
this memcache service is sort of a mix
you know most of it is maybe only used
by a small number of users but there's
some stuff there that lots and lots of
users need to look at and by using
replication as well as sharding they get
you know multiple copies of the very
popular keys and therefore they get sort
of parallel serving of those keys
between the different clusters another
reason to not want to increase the size
of the cluster individual cluster too
much is that all the data within a
cluster is spread over partitioned over
all the memcache servers and any one
front end is typically actually going to
need data from probably every single
memcache server eventually and so this
means you have a sort of n-squared
communication pattern between the front
ends and the memcache servers and to the
extent that they're using TCP for the
communication that involves a lot of
overhead a lot of sort of connection
state for all the different TCP so they
wanted to limit so you know this is N
squared CCP's they want to limit the
growth of this and the way to do that is
to make sure that no one cluster gets to
be too big so this N squared doesn't get
too large
and well related to that is this in
caste congestion business they're
talking about the if a frontman needs
data from lots of memcache servers it's
actually it's gonna send out the
requests more or less all at the same
time and that means this front-end is
gonna get the responses from all the
memcache servers to query it more or
less the same side time and that may
mean dozens or hundreds of packets
arriving here all at the same time which
if you're not careful we'll cause packet
losses that's in caste congestion and in
order to limit how bad that was that you
had a bunch of techniques they talked
about but one of them was not making the
clusters too large so that the number of
memcache has given front-end tend to
talk to and they might be contributing
to the same caste never got to be too
large and a final reason the paper
mentions is that it's or behind this is
is a big network in the data center and
it's hard to build networks that are
both fast like many bits per second and
can talk to lots and lots of different
computers and by splitting the data
center up into these clusters and having
most of the communication go on just
within each cluster that means they need
a smaller they need you know a modest
size fast Network for this cluster and a
modest size you know reasonably fast
network for this cluster but they don't
have to build a single network that can
sort of handle all of the traffic
between among all the computers of the
giant cluster so it limits how expensive
underlying network is on the other hand
of course they're replicating the data
and the two clusters and for items that
aren't very popular and aren't really
going to benefit from the performance
win of having multiple copies this it's
wasteful to sit on all this RAM and you
know we're talking about hundreds or
thousands of servers so the amount of
money they spent on RAM for the memcache
services is no joke so in addition to
the pool of memcache servers inside each
cluster there's also this regional pool
of memcache servers that's
shared by all the clusters in a region
and into this regional pool they then
modify the software on the front end so
that the software on the front end knows
aha
this key the data for this skis actually
not use that often instead of storing it
on a memcache server my own cluster I'm
going to store this not very popular key
in the appropriate memcache server of
the regional pool so this is
the regional pool and this is just sort
of an admission that some data is not
popular enough to want to have lots of
replicas of it they can save money by
only cashing a single copy all right so
that's how they get that's this kind of
Carol replication versus partitioning
strategy they use inside each inside
each region a difficulty they had that
they discuss is that when they want to
create a new cluster in a data center
they actually have a sort of temporary
performance problem as they're getting
that cluster going so you know supposing
they decide to install you know couple
hundred machines to be a new cluster
with the front end new front ends new
memcache errors and then they fire it up
and you know maybe cause half the users
to start using the new cluster I'm gonna
have to use the old cluster well in the
beginning there's nothing in these
memcache servers and all the front end
servers are gonna miss on the memcache
servers and have to go to the databases
and at least at the beginning until
these memcache service gets populated
with all the sort of data that's used a
lot this is gonna increase the load on
the database servers absolutely enormous
leap because before we added the new
clusters maybe the database servers only
saw one percent of the reads because
maybe these memcache servers have a hit
rate of say 99 percent for reads the
only one percent of all that means go to
the database servers before we added the
new cluster if we add a new cluster with
nothing in the memcache servers and send
half the traffic to it it's gonna get a
hundred percent miss rate initially
right and so that'll mean you know we
gone from and so the overall miss write
will now be 50 percent so we've gone
from these database servers serving one
percent of the reads to them serving 50
percent of the reads so at least in this
imaginary example we've been quite
firing up this new cluster we may
increase the load on the databases by a
factor of 50 and chances are the
database servers were running you know
reasonably Coast's the capacity and
certainly not a factor of 50/50 under
capacity and so this would be the
absolute end of the world if they just
fired up a new cluster like that and so
instead they have this cold start idea
in which a new cluster is sort of marked
by some flag somewhere as being in this
cold start state and in that situation
when a front end and the new cluster
misses that actually first first it has
its own local memcache if that says no I
don't have the data then the front end
we'll ask the corresponding memcache in
another cluster in some warm cluster
that already has the data for the data
if it's popular data chances are it'll
be cached my friend and will get its
data and then it will install it in the
local memcache and it's only if both
local memcache and the warm memcache
don't have the data that this is front
end and the new cluster will read from
the database servers and so this is it
and so they run in this kind of cold
mode for a little while the paper I
think mentions a couple hours until the
memcache servers source and the new
clusters start to have all the popular
data and then they can turn off this
cold feature and just use the local
cluster memcache alone it's alright
so another another load problem that the
paper talks about if they ran into and
this is a load problem again deriving
from this kind of look aside caching
strategies is called the thundering herd
and the the scenario
is that supposing we have some piece of
data there's lotsa memcache servers but
there's some piece of data stored on
this memcache server there's a whole
bunch of front ends that are ordinarily
reading that one piece of very popular
data so they're all sending constantly
sending get requests for that data the
memcache server has it in the cache it
answers them and you know their memcache
server is conserve like millions to
million requests per second so we're
doing pretty good and of course there's
some database server sitting back here
that has the real copy of that data but
we're not bothering it because it is
cached well suppose some front-end comes
along and modifies this very popular
data so it's going to send a write to
the database with the new data and then
it's gonna send a delete to the memcache
server because that's the way rights
work so now we've just deleted this
extremely popular data we have all these
front ends constantly sending gets for
that data they're all gonna miss all at
the same time they're all gonna now
having missed send a read request to the
front end database all at the same time
and so now this front-end database is
faced with maybe dozens or hundreds of
simultaneous requests for this data so
the Loews here is gonna be pretty high
and it's particularly disappointing
because we know that all these requests
are for the same key so the database is
going to do the same work over and over
again to respond with the latest written
copy of that key until finally the front
ends get around to installing the new
key in memcache and then people start
hitting again and so this is the
Thundering hurt what we'd really like is
a single you know if a miss if there's a
right and the leads and a miss happens
in memcache we'd like what we'd like is
the for the first front end that misses
to fetch the data and install it and for
the other front ends just like take a
deep breath then wait until the new data
is cached and that's
just what their design does if you look
at the if this thing called Elise which
is different from the pieces were used
to but they call Elise and we start from
scratch in the scenario again let's see
so now suppose we have a popular piece
of data the first front end that asks
for a data that's missing memcache Devo
will send back an error saying oh no I
don't have the data in my cache but it
will install Elise which is a bit unique
number it'll pick a least number install
it in a table and the send this lease
token back to the front end and then
other front ends that come in and ask
for the same Keith they'll simply get a
just be asked to wait you know a quarter
of a second or whatever some reasonable
amount of time by the memcache D because
the memcache key will see a haha I've
already issued the lease for that key
now there's at least potentially a V
Sparky the server will notice it's
already issued at least for the can tell
these ones to wait so only one of the
server's guess Elise this server then
asks for the data from the database when
against the responds back mom
then it sends the put for the new data
with a key and the value of God and the
least proved that it was the one who was
allowed to write the data memcache
people looking for these today aha yeah
you are the the person whose lease was
granted and it'll actually do the
install by and by these other friends
who are told the wait will reissue their
reads now that it will be there and so
we all if all goes well get just one
request to the database instead of
dozens or hundreds and I think it's the
sense in which is the lease is if the
front-end fails at an awkward moment and
doesn't actually request the data from
the database or doesn't get around it
installing it memcache D eventually
memcache D will delete the lease cuz it
times out and the next front end to ask
will get a new lease and will hope that
it will talk to the database and install
new data so yes they answer the question
the lease does up a time out in case the
first front end fails yes yes okay so
these leases are the their solution to
the Thundering Herd problem um another
problem they have is that if one of
these memcache servers fails the most
natural you-know-whats if they don't do
anything special if the memcache server
fails the front ends will send a request
they'll get back a timeout and network
will say jeez that you know I couldn't
contact that host never got a response
and what the real I BRE
software does is it then sense it
requests the database so if a memcache
server fails and we don't do anything
special the database is now going to be
exposed directly to the reads all of
these reefs and I'm catch server West
serving this is the memcache server may
well have been serving you know a
million reads per second that may mean
that the database server would be then
exposed to those million reads per
second then it's nowhere near fast
enough to deal with all those weeds now
Facebook they don't really talk about in
the paper but they do have automated
machinery to replace a failed memcache
server but that takes a while to sort of
set up a new server a new memcache
server and redirect all the front-end
to the new server instead of the old
server so in the meantime they need a
sort of temporary solution and that's
this gutter idea so let's say the scoop
is that we have our front ends we have
the sort of ordinary set of memcache
servers
the database the one of the memcache
service has failed we're kind of waiting
until the automatic memcache server
replacement system replaces this
memcache server in the meantime
friends are sending requests to it they
get a sort of server did not respond
error from the network and then there's
a presumably small set of gutter servers
whose only purpose in life is to eye
they must be idle except when a real
memcache server fails and when the front
end gets an error back saying that get
couldn't contact the memcache server
it'll send the same request to one of
the gutter servers and though the paper
doesn't say I imagine that the front end
will again hash the key in order to
choose which gutter server to talk to
and if the gutter server has the value
that's great
otherwise the front end server will
contact the database server to read the
value and then install it in the
memcache server in case somebody else
answer asks for the same data
so while this means down the gutter
servers will handle basically handle its
request and so they'll be a miss you
know handled by lease leases the
Thundering Herd
they'll be at least I need a Miss on
each of the items that was a no-fail
memcache server so there will be some
load in the database server but then
hopefully quickly this memcache server
will I get all the data that's listen
use and provide good service and then by
and by this will be replaced and then
the friends will know to talk to a
different replacement server and because
they don't and this is today's question
I think that they don't send deletes to
these gutter servers because since a
gutter server could have taken over for
anyone and maybe more than one of the
ordinary memcache service it could
actually have cache the caching any key
so that would mean that and there may be
you know friends talking to it that
would mean that whenever a front-end
needs it to delete a key from memcache
or when the squeal on the database sends
a delete for any key to the relevant
memcache server yeah you know the the
natural design would be that it would
also send a copy of that delete to every
one of the gutter servers and the same
for front ends that are deleting data
they would delete from the memcache
stores but they would also have to leave
potentially from any
MCAD gutter server that would double the
amount of defeats that had to be sent
around even though most of the time
these gutter servers aren't doing
anything and don't cache anything and it
doesn't matter and so in order to avoid
all these extra deletes they actually
fix the gutter servers so that they
delete Keys very rapidly instead of
hanging on to them until they're
explicitly deleted that was answer to
the question all right so I wanna talk a
bit about consistency all this at a
super high level you know the
consistency problem is that there's lots
of copies of the data for any given
piece of data you know there's a copy in
the primary database there's a copy in
the corresponding database server of
each of the secondary regions there's a
copy of that key in each local cluster
in one of the memcache keys in each
local cluster there may be copies of
that key and the gutter servers and
there may be copies of the key in the
memcache servers and the gutter memcache
servers at each other region so we have
lots and lots of copies of every piece
of data running around when a write
comes in you know the stuff has to
happen on all those copies and
furthermore the writes may come from
multiple sources the same key may be
written at the same time by multiple
front ends and this region may be by
friends and other regions too and so
it's this concurrency and multiple
copies and sort of multiple sources of
writes since there's multiple front ends
it creates a lot of opportunity for not
just for there to be stale data but for
data stale data to be left in the system
for long periods of time and so I want
to I want to illustrate what are those
problems actually in a sense we've
already talked a bit about this when
somebody asked why the front ends don't
update why do they delete instead of
updating so that's certainly one
instance of the kind of weather
multiple sources of data and so we have
trouble enforcing correct order but
here's another example of a race an
update race that if they hadn't done
something about it would have left data
indefinitely
stale data and definitely in memcache
it's going to be a similar flavor to the
previous example so supposing we have
client one he wants to read a key but
memcache says it doesn't have the data
it's a Miss so C one's gonna read the
data from from the database and let's
say it gets back some value that you
want
meanwhile client to wants to update this
data so it sends you know its rates he
equals v2 and sends that to the database
and then you know the rule for writes
the code for writes that we saw is that
the next thing we do is delete it from
the database from memcache d.c c2 is
going to delete
ah the key from the database oh that's a
Friday you know it was actually c2
doesn't really know what's in memcache d
but the leading was ever there is always
safe because certainly not gonna cause a
stale data to be deleting won't cause
her to be stilled Leena um and this is
the sense that the paper claims that
delete is idempotent said delete it's
always safe to kabhi but if you recall
the pseudocode for what a read does if
you miss and you read the data from the
database you're supposed to just insert
that data into memcache so client 1 you
know may have been slow and finally gets
around to sending a set RPC two memcache
T but it read version 1 and read a you
know what is now an old outdated version
of the data from the database but it's
going to set that into
set this into memcache and yeah you know
one other thing that happened is that we
know the database is is whenever you
write something I'm database that sends
deletes to memcache D so of course maybe
at this point the database will also
have sent a delete
for k2m caste and so now we get to
deletes but it doesn't really matter
right these lease may already have
happened by the time client one gets
around to updating this key and so at
this point indefinitely the memcache D
will be cashing a stale version of of
this data and there's just no mechanism
anymore or this is them if the system
worked in just this way there's no
mechanism for the memcache D to ever see
to ever get the actual correct value
it's gonna store and serve up stale data
for key K forever
and they because they ran into this and
while they're okay with data being
somewhat out-of-date they're not okay
with data being out of date forever
because users will eventually notice
that they're seeing ancient data and so
they had to solve this they had to make
sure that this scenario didn't happen
they actually solved this this problem
also with the lease mechanism at the
same lease mechanism that we describe
for the Thundering hoard although
there's an extension to the lease
mechanism that makes this work so what
happens is that when memcache descends
back a Miss indication seeing the data
wasn't in the cache it's gonna grant the
lease so we get the Miss indication plus
this lease which is basically just a big
unique number and the memcache server is
gonna remember that the association
between this lease and this key it knows
that somebody out there with a lease to
update this key the new rule is that
when the when the memcache server gets a
delete from either another client or
from the database server the memcache
server is gonna as well as deleting the
item is going to invalidate this lease
so as soon as either these deletes come
in assuming that Elyse arrived first the
memcache server is gonna believe this
lease from its table about leases this
set
is the lease back from the front end now
when the set arrives the memcache server
will look at the lease and say wait a
minute I you don't have a lease for this
key all right invalid if these fit this
key I'm gonna ignore this set so because
the lease has been because one of these
if one of these deletes came in before
the set this sees to be invalid in
invalidated and the memcache server
would ignore this set and that would
mean that the key would note just stay
missing from memcache and the next
client that tried to read that key
you'll get a Miss would read the fresh
data now from the database and would
install it in memcache and presumably
the second time around
the second readers lease would be valid
um you may and indeed you should ask
what happened that the order is
different so supposing these deletes
instead of happening before the set
these deletes were instead to have
happen after the set I want to make sure
this scheme still works then and so how
things would play out then is that since
if these Dilys were late happened after
the set the memcache server wouldn't
delete these from its table of visas
Solis would still be there when the set
came and yes indeed we would still then
it would accept the setting we would be
setting key to a stale value but our
assumption was this time that the
deletes had been late and that means the
Dilys are yet to arrive and when they
when these deletes arrive then this stay
on theta will be knocked out of the
cache and so the stale date will be in
the cache a little bit longer but we
won't have this situation where stale
data is sitting in the cache
indefinitely and never deleted
any questions
lissa machinery okay um to wrap up you
it's certainly fair to view this system
a lot of the complexity of the system as
stemming from the fact that it was sort
of put together out of pieces that
didn't know about each other like it
would be nice for example memcached he
knew about the database I'm understand
memcache D and the database kind of
cooperated in a consistency scheme and
perhaps if Facebook could have at the
very beginning you know predicted the
how things would play out on what the
problems would be and if they have had
enough engineers to work on it they
could have from the beginning built a
system that could provide both all the
things they needed high-performance
multi data center replication partition
and everything and they're having
companies that have done that so the
example I know of that sort of most
directly comparable to the system in
this paper is that if you care about
this stuff you might want to look at it
is Yahoo's peanuts storage system which
in a sort of designed from scratch and
you know different different in many
details but it does provide multi-site
replication with consistency and good
performance so it's possible to do
better but you know all the issues are
present that's just had a more
integrated perhaps elegant set of
solutions
the takeaway so for us from this paper
one is that for them at least and for
many big operations caching is vital
absolutely vital for to survive high
load and the caching is not so much
about reducing latency it's much more
about hiding enormous load from
relatively slow
storage servers that's what a cache is
really doing for Facebook is hiding sort
of concealing almost all the load from
the database servers another takeaway is
that you always in big systems you
always need to be thinking about caching
versus control versus sorry partition
versus replication I mean you need ways
of either formally or informally sort of
deciding how much your resources are
going to be devoted to partitioning and
how much to replication and finally
ideally you'd be able to do a better job
in this paper about from the beginning
integrating the different storage layers
in order to achieve good consistency
okay that is all I have to say please
ask me questions if you have